[Music]
I admit that in the past I've been a
nasty they weren't kidding when they
called me well a witch but you'll find
that nowadays I
did all my ways repentance in the light
and let us switched through yes
and I fortunately know a little magic
cause I'm possessed
[Music]
on behalf of the miserable lonely and
depressed
pathetic
unfortunate
in need this one long exhibition
everyone wants to give the girl and do I
help them yes indeed
the guardianship
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you broke the rules he went to the above
World a man was drowning I had to save
him this obsession with humans has to
stop I just want to know more about them
[Music]
in that Wilderness you become a human
yourself is that even possible
that's what I live for
[Music]
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
I don't know where I don't know how but
I know something's starting right now
watching you see me
someday I'll be
[Music]
secure you're a mermaid that doesn't
make us enemies
[Music]
thank you